there is a whole new world out there of
ways to make money online and I'm not
even talking about out and out scams I
mean just ways to make money as someone
who gives their opinion about things on
the internet on YouTube I often get
emails from people saying hey David you
know you could make a lot more money if
you took this position or that position
or if you called out this person or that
one or that idea or this idea and I even
once had a lunch meeting with a major
talk radio person I don't want to say
who it is but it's someone from the talk
radio industry who said to me you know
David if you could double your income by
pretending to be a conservative instead
of a progressive would you do it and I
said no of course I wouldn't do that and
they said something like it's good to
know what your principles are so you
know how you want to direct your career
or something like that and nevertheless
I never had lunch with that person again
after that meeting but regardless
fortunately our show is doing well
enough that I don't need to do that
right nor would my moral compass even
allow me to concoct some kind of fake
personality or set of positions
that's not my authentic self but there
are lots of ways now that clearly are
great moneymakers and yesterday we were
talking in studio about some of them and
some of them are obvious right like
becoming a conspiracy theorist the
theories themselves don't so much matter
but the thing about conspiracy theories
is that while they won't appeal to a
huge portion of the online world or the
online media audience the people that
buy into your conspiracies will give you
money because they'll see you as having
some kind of courage to tell the truth
about whatever you're talking about so
conspiracy theories are a really big
moneymaker that's one but there's better
ways another really great way to get
people to pour money into your patreon
page or whatever else get you speaking
gigs get you invited on to other shows
is to have an awakening right you have a
political awakening and it mostly works
if you go from being progressive to
conservative in some way because when a
conservative has an awakening and
becomes progressive progressives don't
see it as a miracle we just say yeah
it's
and since they just figured out how the
world works so if you're willing to
denounce your progressivism and concoct
some reason why you're now in the
conservative side because you've seen
the light that is really good for
business and you can make a ton of money
doing that and this will get people to
celebrate you as someone who's willing
to admit mistakes and is now copping to
the ultimate truth really really
profitable Pat's taking notes on that
one cuz he's interested in that one you
can also get a ton of attention and sort
of bolster your rhetorical credentials
by setting up false debates with
artificially narrow parameters to come
off as having owned people or taken them
to school on some issue and it's even
more effective if the people are
completely unskilled and lack any
experience in actual political rhetoric
so that you look really good in alpha
you'll kill it and you will attract the
ton of attention for yourself and that's
actually a good one in general even if
you're not setting up artificially
narrow debates often with false
questions just debate people who were
totally unqualified to be debating right
you will look really good in comparison
another way that you can open the
floodgates of Internet cash give
blindingly obvious advice that you'd
normally find in those discounted
self-help books that you can get for a
penny at the local use book store on
Amazon but wrap up the obvious advice in
either intellectual sounding language or
make the advice seem counterculture or
controversial in some way if you can
hint that people are trying to suppress
your ideas because they're dangerous or
they present some kind of ultimate truth
you'll make that much more money and if
none of these idea sounds good to you a
goldmine is to provide pseudo scientific
arguments to legitimize discriminatory
and prejudicial ideas and if you can say
that actually these are the ultimate
truths that the politically correct
crowd won't admit you can retire early
on that one and race an IQ is one that
comes to mind along those lines and then
last thing if you want just a quick tip
if you're looking to become a successful
online pundit fight against identity
politics while using your own
identity right argue that identity
politics is a terrible malignancy on
society and that white Christian men are
being disenfranchised by identity
politics and that it's time to finally
stand up for white Christian men prepare
for patreon to explode if you're willing
to do that
if I'm missing any let me know because I
want to help the audience make a lot of
money on YouTube as pundits I don't plan
on doing any of this stuff but these are
just some tips for people who might be
looking for ideas I think the political
reawakening one would work best for me
because I already have a platform on a
progressive show right so I'll be
leaving here shortly and you can expect
my Prager you video to come out in a few
weeks can you imagine if there was a big
announcement where pat has seen the
light and he is denouncing his
progressive credentials and is going to
basically you have you could actually
say you were rejoining your family's
conservatism because you've talked about
having a more conservative family and
that would I mean you would be booked by
all sorts of right-wing leaning talking
conferences and also libertarian ones it
would be a goldmine for you I'd make a
new show it would be the path
perspective or the Ford file I'd have to
think of something I like the Ford file
Ford Ford file for freedom that would be
the way or F cubed is actually that yeah
you could do it you could have shirts
that are just an F with a number three
as in cubed send me your thoughts if I'm
missing any ways to make money on
YouTube giving giving your opinion I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show